now with more the author of the price of
principal harvard law professor alan
dershowitz along with the attorney for
former president donald trump alina haba
is with us and the co-host of the five
geraldo rivera alina let me start with
you as the president's attorney let's
talk specifically about the very same
issues we've brought up with jonathan
turley uh as it relates send it back to
the doj they get to write the they get
to redact whatever they want out of it
uh i'm pretty certain it's not going to
come back favorable in any way to trans
to the side of transparency
i agree with you i think that there
won't be very much transparency i would
expect it will get a lot of black
ink all over that piece of paper if i
was the doj abide in doj i'd probably be
redacting everything other than the word
and and the
so we're going to have to see what they
kick back the one good thing
that this judge did say is that he will
take a look at it if it's too um heavily
redacted he will do so himself so he's
encouraging them to try and give us some
sort of clarity i think
though there's a lot of people here that
are just waiting including the trump
team to see
what the basis was when you have a
coordinating
president i mean any person but let
alone a president it just doesn't make
sense
you know professor it's the same office
the same people involved in an operation
crossfire hurricane
i would think that director ray might
have cleaned up that office but
apparently he has not
i think whatever justification they gave
this magistrate who had a clear bias
against donald trump
i've got i've got to believe they want
it redacted for other reasons that's
what my gut tells me what does your gut
tell you
well first of all i predicted exactly
what the judge would do this morning in
an op-ed in newsweek magazine that he
would split the baby that he would say
yes it has to be disclosed but with
redaction but i have a different view
from uh your two previous tests from
jonathan i think they're going to
deliberately not reject a lot of
unfavorable material regarding a donald
trump they're going to leave that in
because there certainly is going to be
material unfavorable if there was an
affidavit for a search warrant then
they're going to redact material that
might be favorable to him so it won't
have anything to do with what's
classified what's unclassified what's
necessary for investigation it will have
much more to do
with how they can redact and unredact in
a way that favors
they don't want this out in the public
donald trump does doesn't that tell you
a lot
it certainly does but i bet the doj
wants different things out in the public
than donald trump does
that already
of course they are but it's much
stronger if they actually can show it
look i agree with you along with
jonathan turley i've seen dozens and
dozens of these redacted act of the
affidavits and they just redact redact
redact and i also agree that the judge
will
overrule them and then they'll have a
right to appeal the next question is
will they get a stay pending appeal or
will the information have to be
disclosed this is just the beginning of
a process and the justice department has
too much control over it
geraldo let's get your legal hat on not
your talk show host hat on and get your
announcements so
and your take
well
i'll leave the redacting or the the
non-redacting to your previous guests
including my other dear friend professor
alan dershowitz
my big beef with the justice department
behavior today in court was the fact
that they made the claim that their
investigation was in the early stages
and that they feared that if they did
not redact that their witnesses or their
confidential informants might be exposed
now they said it was in the early stages
my question is if indeed the
investigation is in the early stages
then how in the world did they get a
search warrant that there was probable
cause that a crime had been committed
and and justifying this extraordinary
raid for the first time in american
history an american president's
residence a former president's residence
in in this unprecedented act was invaded
by 30 fbi agents so it's either
in the early stages or they had probable
cause that a crime had been committed it
does it seems to me that you can't have
both you've got to pick a lane elena how
do you feel about that
i that's 100 accurate and i think you
brought up a good point in your
monologue sean this is the russia hoax
team this is the same people that are
involved there strzok lisa page you know
all these individuals have tainted the
fbi and these are the same individuals
that have been going after donald trump
since the day he came down that
escalator and it will not stop as long
as he's leading in the polls
last 35 seconds of your professor you
got the last 35 seconds yeah let's
remember everybody out there predicted
that reinhardt would just affirm the
justice department and not disclose
anything i predicted that he would do
exactly this that he would redact part
so i'm going to give him a presumption
of uh of credibility and expect that he
will actually accurately trust
trump in social media and he questioned
his morality professor it doesn't get
any more personal than that
i agree but i i'm giving him the benefit
of the doubt he did a very good thing
today i'm giving you the benefit of the
doubt that he hates trump it's obvious
he's put it in writing
he but look everybody predicted that he
would not disclose and he did that you
have to give him the benefit of the
doubt for that let's wait because
the only reason is
in my view he split the baby to use your
term because he needed an out because he
should have never taken the case because
he previously recused himself from the
other case i want an a-plus in this
class
i give you an a-plus sean
thank you alina i appreciate it all
right thank you all hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else